daniel
i gotta tell you there are lots of
shirtless daniel scenes in here now you
started with that iconic shot of you
coming out of the water casino royale
right
now here in this film though we got some
scenes here very nice so would you say
that this is like a nice bookend here
for your scent with the franchise are
you giving fans a parting gift if you
will
am i making you blush daniel
just so much it's ridiculous
i can't i don't know what to say i'm
just i don't know how to watch you still
got it man that you're looking amazing
that's so very nice of you but like i'm
i'm very quite embarrassed now and
i can't look you in the face
daniel come on now you know you got it
man no he is so nice
[Laughter]
he's not gonna say himself but we can
just gush and just
oh
i met your new double-oh she's a
disarming young woman
i get why you shot him
yeah well everyone tries at least once
daniel look it may be your last time as
bond but you are going to forever live
in film history as taking on this iconic
iconic role how excited are you to say
eventually to your kids and reminisce
with them like hey yeah your old man did
that part i don't think they'll really
care that much quite frankly oh come on
now daniel don't be no no no i'll be so
concerned about other things in life i
hope that they won't have to be
concerned about that yeah
you can imagine where i've come back to
play
listen i'm very proud of what we've done
i'm so you know so lucky to have been
sort of had this this opportunity for
the past 16 years and you know
what happens in the future it just feels
like i'm gonna it's gonna take me 15
years to unpick all this to figure out
what what just happened
because it really does i mean as much as
you know sometimes it was a slog it's
gone like that it's just it's you know i
i remember flying down the thames being
announced as james bond like it was
yesterday oh my gosh well you have
served this role so so well daniel
congratulations sir
here you are carrying on the 007 code
name forward that is of course no
spoiler there but what does that mean to
you especially as a woman and as a woman
of color it's something that i've had to
really take my time to think about
because i come from a working class
background jamaican background me and my
family have had conversations over the
years of how we're going to put our mark
on the world and what our
children are going to feel and relish
from you know in in the legacy that we
hopefully produce for them even being
cast in a bond movie isn't something
that was in my sphere you know i'm a
manifesto and i have like kind of tried
to manifest a lot in my career and this
just
passed me i didn't even realize
the world's moved on commander bond you
were double o two years
so stay in your lane you get in my way i
will put a bullet in your knee
[Music]
the one that works i thought you two
would get along so
it was nice to be taken by surprise and
not have to like really push hard like i
have done the last 10 years to even get
in the room i was really grateful to be
introduced to barbara brockley by play i
did in london it was all kind of like
synchronicity was really very much
happening around the whole thing um so
so now yeah nomi came about it just
feels
it feels wonderful but i haven't really
got the words i'm still
trying to figure it out maybe i'll in a
couple of years when i'm just on a
random other set somewhere i'll be like
god that happened um but i i don't know
and i think it's okay to not know i
think sometimes you should just process
slowly and allow yourself to yeah to
gather your thoughts and and stay
present so i'm just staying present to
enjoy the moment with these guys and
celebrating everything there is i i like
that style i like your speed to it all
but i think you're going to know very
well that you more than deserve a space
in that room and you have made your mark
when fans start seeing this film because
thank you do an extraordinary job hey
daniel i know you're saying goodbye to
this role but we are so pumped to say
hello to you again and knives out too
it is not a donut hole
but a smaller donut with its own hole
and our donut
is not whole at all all starcasts coming
at us again what was it like shooting
all over greece and then what what
exactly can we expect with this uh i
can't tell you but um
it's uh it's going to be great it's
going to be very different and yeah just
a wonderful wonderful thing to shoot
yeah the name's bond
james bond
how would you say the role has changed
your life this role of portraying james
bond it's so impossible to sort of kind
of quantify it and sort of i don't know
put
put a kind of an explanation on it i've
changed
immeasurably since i began this in my
professional life and in my personal
life clearly hopefully i have a little
bit of my personal life over 15 years
i try to um you know
self-examine a little bit but um
it's uh
it's given me
a confidence that i didn't have when i
started off this confidence to sort of
try and make the best of what you have
and make the best movies we can that's
all i've ever tried to do with these
these films i've always said you know
every time we've started thinking about
them every time you started trying to
get a new one off the ground i said can
we get the best can we just get the best
like lachanze like leia like
ben and rafe
it's just like we have a beautiful
beautiful bunch of people
actors
and some of the best crew in the world
and that's all i ever ever wanted out of
this